your confession
we have multiple witnesses and we have
this
you don't understand i had to do it why
i don't know possibly destroy the
universe it was what he was about to do
[Music]
destroy the universe well
you stopped him good job doc
i'm serious and i don't know if i
stopped him you saw yourself his body
fell through
the damage may already be done it may be
too late
what damage ah that'll that'll take some
explaining
okay you're in some serious trouble and
we got all the time in the world
talk okay okay i've been completely
cooperative
i'll tell you everything how much do you
know about
wormholes only what i've seen in the
movies
pendleton space that kind of thing yeah
exactly
i won't go too much into the science of
it but my team and i
working on developing a stable wormholes
a way to instantly travel
from one point to another about six
months ago
we had a breakthrough we we actually did
it
you made a wormhole yeah
we managed to open one right in the
laboratory we punched a hole
in the space-time continuum an actual
wormhole right there in front of our
eyes okay
and where did it go to philadelphia
oh spectacular that would have been uh
may nice to meet you in philly huh
i don't know i ought to prefer to lie
please
let me continue all right go ahead
thank you when we first opened it we had
no idea where it led to
we ran all the tests we could think of
on it but eventually
we knew we'd have to send something
through it so
we got a video camera and attached a
locator device to it and sent it through
we left the complex and activated the
locator it showed that the camera was
kilometers away we got there in two
hours and eventually found it halfway up
a tree
is this going anywhere apart from
philadelphia yes
yes i'm getting there it's crucial that
you know the full history before i
explain
why i had to kill him may i continue
please do we retrieved the camera only
to find that the battery was dead
we thought that maybe the trip through
the wormhole had somehow fried the
electronics
drained the battery we got it back to
the lab and connected it to a charger
hoping maybe it recorded some of the
footage before whatever it was and
killed the battery
and had it yes but this was the part
that shocked us
the first message that appeared on its
display was
chip full and simultaneously one of the
technicians yelled over that there was
nothing wrong with the battery
and it's simply been used up drained
meaning a standard hollow chip will
store 36 hours of recording
the battery for that camera model lasts
for 48 hours
we retrieved the camera in two hours
detective yet the battery was depleted
and the storage device was full
we checked the contents of the chip it
had a full
36 hours of footage on it
so the camera was damaged and broke
garbage to the chip
no it worked perfectly the footage we
pulled from it began in the lab showing
me smiling into the lens
then going through the wormhole then
into a blinding light sunshine then
green then blue sky
as near as we could tell it exited the
wormhole 35 meters in the air
had fallen and landed in a tree
luckily it ended up pointing up in the
sky
we were able to determine from weather
conditions in the face of the moon
captured by the camera
that it had not only traveled 150
kilometers through space
but it had also traveled nine days back
in time
back in time time travel yes
well if you're gonna start jerking us
around i'm not i swear it
the wrong hole had not only bent space
but time
too so you built a time machine
unintentionally yeah
but we had we kept experimenting with it
over the following weeks and months
sending more and more objects through as
well as sterile biological samples until
we were able to accurately calibrate the
exit point both spatially and temporally
to a high degree of accuracy
what does that mean we were able to
create wormholes to within 1.5 meters of
our intended destination
location and to within 12 minutes of our
intended destination
time what has this got to do with you
killing dr snow
everything well i'm about to use that
time machine yours to skip forward to
tonight
say when you arrived at the lab okay
it was important you understood what the
device was before i explained
you've explained now talk
all right this evening i was at home
reading
when the lab security system telephoned
me it told me that there have been an
intrusion into the restricted materials
compound
that's where we keep all the dangerous
chemicals biological agents weapons tech
you know that kind of thing
it said that dr snow had broken in and
removed eight liters of rx 52
rx 52 it's an engineered virus a bio
weapon it causes a severe rash within 10
minutes of exposure
followed by pustules erupting on the
skin it's not lethal and runs its course
about four hours with no lasting effects
okay go on but while rx-52 is not lethal
it is still very dangerous its intended
use is to create
mass chaos panic but not fatalities
that much of it is enough to infect tens
of thousands of people
i jumped him into my car and drove to
the lab
when i got there and entered the
building the lab's computer greeted me
and announced that i had a new message
from dr snow
i gotta complete a message for me and
that's when i realized what i had to do
which was i had to stop him
whatever the cost what was the message
from dr snow
it was a last will and testament of
sorts
he explained his plan every detail of
what he was going to do
in his own words he was going to become
a hero legendary
he'd been planning it for some time
apparently he was going to use the
device to send himself back in time
along with a shotgun
200 rounds of ammunition and 8 liters of
rx-5
he'd set the spatial coordinates to
manhattan new york and the temporal
coordinates to 4 am
on the 11th of september 2001
what yeah he was going to send himself
back in time 73 years to the morning of
the attacks
are you familiar with what happened on
september the 11th 2001 detective
of course i learned about it in history
class
we helped it what was he planning to do
[Music]
2973 people died in those attacks
most of them in the old world trade
center towers
he was going to stop them what there was
no way he could stop him
those planes come from completely
different parts of the country
he wasn't going to physically stop the
planes he was going to have the two
buildings evacuated
he was going to connect the canisters of
rx-52 four leaders in each tower to the
ventilation systems
he would then contact the authorities
and announce that he was a terrorist who
was about to release a large
quantity of the smallpox virus into the
both buildings
smallpox it was a deadly virus which was
eliminated in the 20th century
but was believed for a time to have been
held in stockpiles of biological warfare
his plan was twofold if the authorities
acted and as he hoped they would have
evacuated both buildings
if they didn't he would have released
the rx-52 by remote into the building's
ventilation systems
the physical symptoms from the rx-52
presenting would make people believe
that it was truly smallpox
they would panic fleeing the building or
at least try to leave
going down the lower levels of the
authorities and active quarantine
procedures
my god yeah ingenious
the people behind the attacks would have
had no way of knowing but if his plan
succeeded
those planes would have collided with
two empty buildings
what was the weapon for that was in case
he was discovered
he thought of everything in case he was
found planting the rx-52
his intention was to get into a gunfight
which would have caused the authorities
to turn off according off
whichever tower he was found in he would
have told them between shots that they
were
too late i've already done with the
tower
again this would have caused both
buildings to be attacked okay
let me get this straight dr snow
was gonna use your device a time machine
to stop one of the worst atrocities our
country has ever experienced
yeah and you stopped him yeah he had to
be stopped i couldn't let him interfere
why not
he could have saved thousands of lives
no
no no my god no he would have changed
history
history is fragile don't you get it
having succeeded history as we know it
would have been completely rewritten
he would have created a paradox we have
no idea what would have happened
it could have decimated the fabric of
space time destroyed
existence itself don't you get it
sit down please
sit down
we'll get into the physics of it later
continue with your story
what did you do when you listened to the
message i ran
as fast as i could to the wormhole
chamber when i got there he already
activated it beside the door
were the canisters of rx 52 with the
shotgun and ammunition on top
i screened it in the stock he turned to
look at me
sneered and told me i was too late he
was standing in front of the wormhole
there was no way i could have reached
him in time to stop him going through
even if he went through without his
equipment he could still create
catastrophic damage to the timeline
simply by his presence there i had no
choice i could not let him step through
detective
i grabbed the shotgun from where it was
and aimed at it i gave him one
[Music]
you